be free make mistakes try things
this is the job about your imagination
you're making a movie influenced by life
you're making a character influenced by
a human and you want to make it as human
as possible
what is their desire desires at the root
of
everything i have not been to
a traditional drama school i've been
working for 25 years
and i learned by doing and i piece
together
different things that are helpful for me
that i want to share with you
greenspurian acting is kind of the
purest form of acting because you're
inventing
both what's outside of you and what's
inside of you as an actor
we're gonna do a scene where i've just
found out my boyfriend's cheating on me
and i'm entering his apartment you want
to
scour the space to see what you might
use that would be emotionally relevant
help the camera catch what's being read
[Music]
get very close to the camera to give a
feeling
of what you might be going through
when i was asked to play jackie kennedy
i was terrified which is always a good
reason to do something
i always work with a dialect coach for
jackie every single syllable every
breath have to be exactly the same
when you see where the breaths are you
can read what is sort of happening
underneath what the person is saying
this is a joyful
creative process that you don't need to
be afraid of making mistakes
thank you that's how you sneeze on cute
your job is to imagine someone else's
life that is what we do we say
i wonder what that person feels and
thinks
and that's the experience in a movie
theater you're sharing
this social experience with other people
for two hours
caring about someone else's life it's
the act of empathy
i'm natalie portman and this is my
master class
you